-Our next guest
is a best-selling
author and historian.
His book
"Humankind: A Hopeful History"
is out in paperback now.
Please welcome to the show
Rutger Bregman, everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show, Rutger.
-Thanks. It's great to be here.
-You are our first
Dutch historian
in the history of the show.
We are honored to have you.
I believe you are
a very famous Dutch historian
in your home country.
I became aware of you
when you were at --
Is it the economic forum
in Davos?
-Yeah, the World Economic Forum.
-The World Economic Forum
in Davos.
You were on stage in a room
full of very wealthy people.
-Mm-hmm.
-They had obviously invited you.
You did not charge the stage.
You were an invited speaker.
And I became aware of you
because you said some things
that the people in the room
did not respond very well to.
Let's just take a quick look at
that clip.
-Almost no one raises the real
issue of tax avoidance, right?
And of the rich just not paying
their fair share.
I mean, it feels like I'm at
a firefighters conference
and no one's allowed to speak
about water.
This is not rocket science.
I mean, we can talk for
a very long time about
all these stupid philanthropy
schemes.
We can invite Bono once more,
but come on.
We got to be talking
about taxes.
That's it --
taxes, taxes, taxes.
All the rest is [bleep],
in my opinion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It did not go over well.
Obviously, you must have had
some expectation
it wouldn't go over well
when you were saying it.
-You know, for some reason,
they haven't invited me back.
-That was your last Davos.
[ Laughter ]
-I was wondering,
was it something I said?
[ Laughter ]
-That happened,
and you wrote this book,
and I had an expectation
based on that.
"Oh, here's a guy who points out
what's wrong,"
especially with things
such as income inequality,
but you actually wrote a book
about how humankind is better
than we all give it credit for,
and that human beings,
at their core, are decent.
What led you to want to write
a book about this topic?
-Well, look, this is really
a book for those who have lost
their faith in humanity,
and I think there are
quite a few of us today.
You could summarize it
as a 400-page treatise on
anthropology and sociology
and philosophy and archaeology
in which I'm trying to
make the case
that Ted Lasso is
actually right,
that he's the realist.
He has a very realistic take on
human nature
and that most people, deep down,
are pretty decent.
-And one of the things I thought
when I was reading it,
was this a hard sell
to publishers?
Because it does strike me that
a lot of the books that you see
and a lot of the books you hear
about are about
what's wrong with things.
And at the core,
you're writing optimistically
that more is right than wrong.
-Yeah, exactly.
I'm a historian,
and if you study history,
it's mostly about
wars, wars, more wars,
and if there's not a war, then
we call it the interbellum,
right,
the period in between wars.
So yes, it was a hard sell.
There's this really old theory
in Western culture that says
that our civilization is just a
thin layer, just a thin veneer,
and that below that lies
raw human nature,
that supposedly, people,
deep down, are just selfish.
And that idea comes back again
and again, you know,
in our philosophy,
in our culture, in our movies,
in our plays, in our novels.
In the book, I talk about "Lord
of the Flies," for example,
this book that we were all
forced to read in high school.
So not very optimistic about
human nature.
So it's deeply embedded
in our culture.
-There's a fascinating chapter
in the book where you actually
do some research and you try to
wonder what actually
would have happened in
a "Lord of the Flies" situation,
and you found, basically,
a story where this happened,
where some kids were shipwrecked
and the opposite happened.
They became a very functional
group of kids who had to survive
for a great, long time
without any adult supervision.
-I was just wondering whether it
had ever really happened, right?
Because you can write a novel,
but it would be so interesting
to find out what really happens
when you drop
kids on an uninhabited island.
It turns out that it's difficult
to do a scientific experiment
like that.
[ Laughter ]
Most parents are not
easily convinced
to volunteer their kids.
But then I looked at
whether there's ever been
a natural experiment,
and it turned out that
it did happen in 1965.
There were six kids from Tonga,
which is an island group
in the Pacific Ocean,
who were bored with school.
They didn't like
the school meals.
They thought
it was pretty boring.
They said, "Well, let's go on
an adventure."
And they "borrowed" a boat and
then ended up in a storm already
on the first night, drifted for
eight days, and then shipwrecked
on this island, and survived
there for 50 months.
And you know, if this would have
been a Hollywood movie,
people would say, "Oh, this is
so sentimental, so naive.
This is worse than
'Love, Actually.'"
[ Laughter ]
But it really happened.
They survived by staying
friends, by working together.
It's an example of what
some scientists call
"survival of the friendliest."
-Obviously, you don't gloss over
the fact that there have been --
our history's full of
atrocities,
from war to other things.
And how do you reconcile that
with your core thesis?
-It's one of the ironies,
obviously, if you write a book
about human decency, is that you
have to go on for
hundreds of pages about all the
dark chapters in human history.
Obviously, there's no simple,
single explanation.
What I do try to point out
is that the joker,
it does exist, right?
Those kind of people do exist,
but they're very rare,
the kind of people who just
enjoy being sadistic
and enjoy hurting other people.
But they're a really
small minority.
Most people who are on the wrong
side of history actually believe
they're doing the right thing,
you know?
Very often, we can do terrible
things in the name of loyalty,
in the name of friendship, in
the name of comradeship, right?
And that is the dark truth
about us, right?
Sometimes I wonder, how will
the historians of the future
look back on us, right?
Because we may be doing some
things today
that are really bad,
just as we can look back on,
say, the Middle Ages
and think torture was bad,
slavery was really bad,
et cetera.
But maybe today, we're doing
some really bad stuff as well.
-Well, I hope I'm not around
for that reckoning.
[ Laughter ]
I want to tie back to what
we said in the beginning.
Obviously, the people
in the audience at Davos
is a perfect example.
They were there to talk about
how to make the world
a better place.
-Mm-hmm.
-And yet they reacted negatively
to the idea that
paying your fair share is
probably the quickest way
to solve a lot of problems.
-Mm-hmm.
-Were you surprised that they
didn't see that disconnect?
-Well, look, the short summary
of the book would be
most people are pretty decent,
but power corrupts.
Power is this incredibly
dangerous drug
that often makes you
less empathetic.
A lot of people think that
the world is ruled by selfish,
evil global elites or whatever,
but if you actually go to Davos
and you meet these people,
you realize that the truth
is much more disturbing.
You go there and they turn out
to be pretty friendly, right?
They just don't see the issue.
They arrive in their private
jets and then watch
a David Attenborough movie about
how we're wrecking the planet
and they're like,
"Ooh, this is really bad,"
and then they go back
in their private jet.
So I think that's much more
disturbing because if it would
be a conspiracy,
you can just roll it up,
but this goes much deeper.
-So, I feel like I've ended on
a negative point,
and I really don't want to do
that because the book put me
in such a good mood
and made me so optimistic.
So I want to give you one last
chance to say something nice.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, I will.
-I feel like I cornered you
into a really bad place.
-It often happens.
-Yeah.
-What you assume in other people
is what you get out of them.
So if we assume that most people
are just selfish,
then that's the kind of world
we're going to create.
If we turn it around,
I think we can move to
a radically different
kind of world.
If you assume that most kids are
naturally curious and creative,
we can build very different
kind of schools.
I've got one chapter in the book
about the criminal justice
system in Norway.
It's pretty astounding.
So, these criminals have
the freedom to socialize
with the guards,
to watch movies,
to build a bit of an education.
They've got their own band,
actually.
They've got their own
music label,
which is called
Criminal Records.
-There you go.
-In almost every single way,
it doesn't look like a prison.
But then you look at
the recidivism rate,
the chance that someone will
commit another crime
once he or she gets
out of prison.
And it's nowhere as low
as in Norway.
So it is counterintuitive.
It sounds a little bit, I don't
know -- How do you say that?
Naive, but if you look at
the facts behind it, it works.
-Alright. Well, there we go.
I think that's a very nice way
to leave this,
which is we should all look for
the best in other people,
and maybe they'll deliver on it.
And thanks so much
for being here.
I really appreciate it.
You guys, that's Rutger Bregman.
"Humankind: A Hopeful History"
is really wonderful.
It's out in paperback now.